you collaborated with an absolute icon
on this album gladys knight i heard it
was a friend at your recording studio
who literally you know just called her
up and asked her to do this what went on
in your mind when when you got to meet
her she's not just a celebrity she's
someone that has transcended that and
is respected in all genres of music
[Music]
when you're in the studio
as a songwriter
hearing of
an icon like that sing the words that
you created it's just mind-blowing to go
and then on top of that oh she's singing
with me like you know it's not just that
she's singing these words i i helped
write she's singing them with me
time tequila in therapy is basically my
motto of the last three years and also
the name of your album which do you lean
more towards these days i mean a lot of
therapy going on uh i would say yeah you
know a lot of self-care and realizing
how important that is
what does it mean that your music
continues to connect with fans after all
these years the longer this goes
you know the more meaningful it is
because it's a you know it's a fickle
business and you know this this type of
success is
fleeting and you know temporary but
the longer that we can ride it it's just
sweeter every time
[Music]